montagnes du yunnan au sud est de la
chine
un paysage extraordinaire avec des pics
rocheux de près de 800 mètres de haut
c'est dans cet endroit incroyable que se
déroule une des manches de la coupe du
monde de wingsuit le sport le plus
dangereux qu'ils existent ces seize
coups d'adrénaline vont se jeter dans le
vide
vêtu d'une combinaison en forme d'aile
ils peuvent planer comme des oiseaux
parmi eux l'un des champions français de
la discipline
vincent d'eskhol se prépare pour son
premier saut d'entraînement alors on a
encore le sourire mais encore deux trois
conneries un bon exutoire ça tu vois ça
permet de évacuer la pression qui monte
sur ce qu'il faut c'est qu'à pas de
pression tu vois dans le mien aussi tu
as si t'as pas un petit peu peur un peu
les faut être un peu de pression pas bon
comme vincent tous s'apprêtent à
accomplir le plus vieux rêve de l'homme
voler de ses propres ailes en jeu le
titre de pilote le plus rapide du monde
est ce que la piste d'atterrissage et
libre à ses pieds 2700 mètres du vide
un saut dans dix secondes pour vincent
[Musique]
plongez extrême à plus de 200 km heure
avec ses hommes volants créé par des
parachutistes il ya une dizaine d'années
le wingsuit est aujourd'hui un sport
pratiqué par quelques milliers de
casques ou dont une centaine de français
attirés par le vide est accro à la
vitesse grâce à sa combinaison
le pilote peut littéralement planer sur
une longue distance et prolé de près les
falaises ou les gorges de montagne comme
sur ces images de vincent prises dans
les alpes l'hiver dernier
[Musique]
depuis qu'en 2011 l'américain jeff
corbis a fait le buzz avec cette vidéo
en passant par le trou de ces montagnes
du yunnan
les meilleurs pilotes se donnent rendez
vous au coeur de la chine pour en
découdre
mais cette soif d'adrénaline n'est pas
sans risque lors des 12 derniers mois 27
pilotes de wingsuit ont trouvé la mort
dans le monde
la plateforme de sault se trouve tout en
haut de cette montagne pour atteindre le
site
il faut parcourir un long chemin est
d'abord emprunté ce téléphérique pour
vincent et ses compagnons les choses
sérieuses commencent ce matin pour se
qualifier il va devoir réaliser le
meilleur chrono possible on va s'élancer
de la
ce que redoute vincent et les autres
pilotes c'est le vent le long des
falaises qui pour elle est projetée sur
la paroi il jette donc quelques petites
gouttes d'eau dans le vide pour déceler
le courant d'air fatale effectivement on
va sauter ne voit quand même descendre
quasiment à la verticale pendant au
moins 100 m et du coup on a envie de
voir ben tu vois si par hasard on n'est
pas protégé une fif et imagine semble
être en dessous il y aurait un flux
d'air particulier tu vois les montagnes
c'est spécial as tu vois nulle dans des
endroits avec des traits torture et le
relief est très torturée les adversaires
de vincent viennent du monde entier
américains australiens ou encore
chiliens comme sebastian coe viennent
tout va bien les 38 prêt pour le saut
d'entraînement mais il est plus
dangereux pour vincent ce sont ces deux
hommes au casque noir
julian le sud africain et noah
l'américain de pilotes sponsorisé par la
ville de dubaï avec un budget
d'entraînement illimitée ils sont les
grands favoris suis toujours optimiste
faut aller tout droit resté constant
avoir confiance quand ne pas être
arrogant et tout devrait bien se passer
mais vincent a aussi ses chances
contrôleurs aériens dans la vie il a 7
ans de pratique de wingsuit et plus de
mille sauts derrière lui pourtant ta vie
ne tient qu'à quelques centimètres de
toiles sa combinaison qu'il va enfiler
dans quelques minutes
vu comme ça ça ressemble pas grand chose
mais c'est un sacré d'autres
technologies
la ramq là dedans tu as une dizaine de
matériaux différents dès qu'on va se
mettre à descendre l'air va alimenter
ses et coop et la wind cries de la
second souffle et en fait techniquement
c'est comme si on a la surface de 2,48
quoi c'est comme si tu souhaitais avec
deux parapluies et avec ça on arrive à
non seulement a plané sacrément bien sur
plusieurs kilomètres mais en pousse à
des vitesses de daigne à contrôler tout
ça un contrôle particulièrement délicat
lâché dans le vide à plus de 200
kilomètres heure
la moindre erreur de pilotage peut
conduire à l'accident mortel 100 % des
accidents des cinq dernières années
c'est 100 % d'erreurs humaines en fait
on essaye d'imiter pas le monde des
oiseaux mais ça s'arrête là quoi
seule façon pour ces hommes volants
d'atterrir un parachute qu'il porte dans
le dos au total la panoplie coûte en
moyenne 4000 euros et voilà alors pour
marcher tu vois c'est bien rigolo aussi
vincent est fin prêt les séances de
qualifications vont commencer les
pilotes seront classés en fonction de
leur temps les premiers s'élance et il
ya un homme qui est particulièrement
vigilant niro ces panels l'organisateur
de ce grand prix de chine au parfait ici
les conditions sont bonnes même si le
vent se lève un peu pour lui une seule
priorité que tous ces champions reste en
vie ok nous sommes le score le plus
dangereux sur terre on ne peut pas le
nier c'est dangereux de sauter d'une
montagne avec un parachute et il n'y a
pas de garantie c'est comme à la
naissance de la formule 1 vous pouvez
être le meilleur pilote et le risque
existe toujours
alors que vincent s'apprête à sauter
1000 mètres plus bas
une personne scrutent le ciel avec une
attention toute particulière
marine sa femme depuis deux ans
rencontré dans un centre de parachutisme
il partage la passion des sports
extrêmes il ya quelques jours elle
s'était elle même en parachute de l'une
des plus autour de la capitale de la
malaisie
aujourd'hui les conditions sont idéales
mais pour marine quand vincent saute le
risque zéro n'existe pas si le saut est
simple
je sais que les conditions sont très
bonnes je n'ai pas trop de stress
par contre si je sais que c'est un sont
engagés on
niveau qui à quoi que ce soit qui peut
devenir un petit peu compliqué à ce
moment là oui je commence à beaucoup
beaucoup stressé
donc ça dépend en fait du niveau du sol
vincent doit parcourir un kilomètre 700
en ligne droite le plus rapidement
possible
au bout de quelques secondes il atteint
déjà les 232 km heure presque la vitesse
d'une formule 1 je le vois il est passé
on voit la trace avec le fumigène
vincent vient de passer la ligne
d'arrivée matérialisé par ces caméras
elle mesure son temps au millième de
seconde près en trois secondes 38.7
allez pas trop bas
moins de 35 secondes après avoir sauté
vincent ouvre son parachute
il vole encore à presque 100 90 km heure
santi suis pas mal
[Musique]
et qu'il est content
mais le temps de vincent est loin d'être
le meilleur
le problème c'est que selon le règlement
les moins bien classées vous rencontrer
ceux qui ont réalisé les meilleurs
chronos qui veut dire que demain je vais
affronter quelques semaines de encore
plus rapide donc il va falloir envoyer
la purée sérieusement s'il veut gagner
le français va devoir prendre des
risques mais pour les pilotes de
wingsuit l'essentiel n'est pas toujours
de l'emporter ces sportifs se comporte
comme une famille unie qui a subi de
nombreux drames avant de retourner à
leur hôtel
tous vont se recueillir devant un
monument érigé dans les montagnes
chinoises en hommage aux victimes de
leur sport
[Musique]
avez vous demandé une minute de silence
pour la mémoire de john à thann depuis
que le grand prix de chine existe cinq
de ses participants ont perdu la vie
notamment le vainqueur de l'édition 2013
mort en juillet dernier john adams
flores était colombien il avait 32 ans
c'était mort tragique mais ils sont
morts aussi en vivent leur rêve
on essaye de faire en sorte de justement
de tirer les leçons de ces accidents
parce que justement on a perdu tellement
d'amis j'ai aussi des potes qui sont en
fauteuil roulant et qui peuvent pas
sauter qui peuvent pas voler c'est pas
le plus important de finir premier de
cette compétition tu vaut mieux rester
en vie pour en profiter tous les jours
en attendant pour vincent c'est demain
que va se jouer ce championnat de chine
et à 8000 km de là dans les pyrénées
orientales
ses parents croient dur comme fer en ses
chances notamment son père raymond qui
n'a pas touché à la chambre de vincent
depuis son départ de la maison la
chambre de 25 en bois la passionne les
avions les hélicoptères allaient tous ya
là partout partout une fascination qui
remonte à ses 10 ans même si vincent
n'est pas devenu pilote professionnel
c'est la passion du vol a été comblée
avec la pratique du winch toutes les
sensations évanouies suite sont
peut-être même plus forte que dans un
avion moins définitive on est engraissé
est tous là il libre c'est lui qui
volent c'est pal avions qui volent c'est
lui avec sa femme josette ils y ont
toujours soutenu moi je le vois volée je
rêve pour lui je rêve à travers lui je
me dis mais ça doit être inouïe ce qu'il
vit iwuy et malgré la distance
ils attendent la course de vincent avec
impatience j'ai toujours dit prends du
plaisir et puis et voilà c'est tout un
maire les maris qui sont allés lui
premier quand même allez allez allez
travailler cinq domaines
en espérant que moi il se qualifie voilà
voilà rassurés bus volant
[Musique]
retour en chine où le soleil se lève sur
la montagne tianmen c'est le grand jour
pour vincent et les autres athlètes
en chine le wingsuit est devenu un sport
très populaire
une centaine de journalistes a fait le
déplacement et la chaîne nationale va
retransmettre l'événement en direct
évidemment c'est moi qui vais gagner
près de 390 millions de téléspectateurs
ont suivi la précédente édition soit six
fois et demie la population française un
vrai engouement national
la compétition peut commencer
mais au bout de quelques sauts sebastian
le pilote chilien va être victime d'un
accident
son parachute que l'on voit ici sur la
droite
c'est en mêlée et dérive dangereusement
vers la montagne
le pilote s'écrase dans la jungle
très vite son collègue donne sa position
à sentir la au juste après le pylône il
est juste au dessus les secours
interviennent rapidement
[Musique]
sebastian c'est mélissa j'ai une radio
dit moi quand tu as réussi à descendre
de l'arbre
ok
plus de peur que de mal le chilien a pu
atterrir dans les arbres sans trop de
casse
la compétition peut reprendre c'est
maintenant au tour de vincent il y a
deux ans il avait obtenu la médaille de
bronze
mais aujourd'hui il se retrouve face à
un adversaire bien plus expérimentés que
lui
et cette fois les sauts sont
éliminatoires
e
dans ce duel les deux pilotes sont très
proches tout au long de la course
[Musique]
ils franchissent la ligne d'arrivée
ensemble impossible de déterminer le
vainqueur à l'oeil nu
ils ont beau être en plein vol je suis
en plein suspense
[Musique]
malheureusement même s'il atterrit en
premier vincent est battu pour quatre
dixièmes de seconde
avec émoi
malgré la défaite ils la jouent sert
plus belles courses mec c'était rapide
c'était vraiment très serré jusqu'à la
ligne d'arrivée c'était vraiment une
belle course
c'était hyper serré tout du long on
était côte à côte ces turbulents plus en
l'air donc fallait faire gaffe à pas se
rentrer dedans c'était une belle course
j'ai fait de mon mieux et pour moi il
n'y a pas de regret pour vincent la
compétition s'arrête dès le premier tour
mais pour lui elle restera un bon
souvenir d'autant plus que tous les
pilotes sont rentrés sains et saufs
notamment son ami chilien qui avait fini
dans les arbres côté résultats sans
surprise les deux grands favoris
sponsorisé par la ville de dubaï
prennent les deux premières places avec
à la clé trente mille dollars pour le
vainqueur
vincent lui a déjà prévu de revenir l'an
prochain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]